[Music]
today or at least now we're reviewing
the RX 7700 XT that's this card it is
very large for a 7700 XT especially
because this was the 6800 6800 sorry my
mind is on the better card this was a
7800 XT that we got for review uh so
we'll be looking at the 7700 XT now we
already reviewed the 78 as sort of
spoiled there we largely pointed to the
6800x he has a really interesting
alternative while it's still on the
market for today's review of the 77 we
are primarily focusing on whether it's
worth it to spend the extra 50 bucks to
go from a 7700 XT to a 7800 XT or kind
of a 6800 XT we'll cover that point as
well uh because that is the price
difference so the 77 Baseline is
supposed to be 450 the 7800 XT is
Baseline supposed to be 500 not a huge
gap there there are much larger gaps
than any of these line up than that one
and so probably you're going to end up
getting largely pushed towards one or
the other depend down the market
conditions at the time you're buying it
all right of that let's get started and
talk about whether one of these is
better than the other answer is yes
before that this video is brought to you
by fantax and the g300a mesh edition
case the phantax g300a revives the a
series approach to airflow that fan text
began really pushing with the p400a that
we liked previously the new g300a comes
in a few variants based on fan count and
uses of the phantax ultra fine front
mesh that allows for a higher airflow
without double stacking filters as we've
shown in the past the g300a eclipse is a
compact Tower supporting ATX boards and
you can learn more at the link in the
description below so if you want the
wider comparison of amd's new 7800 XT
against things like Nvidia Alternatives
like the 4060 TI the two versions there
are the 4070 or amd's own prior options
then check out the 7800 XT review This
Is Us telling you there's a lot of depth
there this one's very specifically
focused on this one comparison to recap
one key point though I as the 6800 XT
Fades from General availability which
will sadly happen it's going to go away
we will be left with the 7800 XT or you
go above it to the 7900 XT 700 GRE it
exists but not really it was I think a
China only or mainly launch and so it's
not really all around the world so
you're left with a 78x079 XT now as that
becomes true the 7800 XT is at least not
bad value compared to some of the other
stuff we've looked at so the 4070 or
especially the 4060 TI the 7800 XT
despite losing to the 6800 XT at least
proved once and for all that the 4060 TI
16 gigabyte which cost the same is a
massively greedy waste and the 4060 TI 8
gigabyte isn't safe either it remains
kind of suspect the 77 XT will put
pressure there as well so uh the 7700xc
we suspect will further threaten the
4060 TI's existence you'll see that
today but it may be close enough to 500
cards to skip it if you can afford the
jump quick recap of the prices we went
over these in the last review as well
but if you missed it the 4070 TI is 800
or so the 40 70 is 600 or so 460 TI is
around 400 to 500 with the larger
capacity and then the 4060 is 300.
that's on videos immediately relevant
current gen lineup amds has the 7900 XT
at 800 and then they've got everything
from a 6700 XT at 330 up to a 69.50 XT
at 630 or so with the 68 XT somewhere in
the middle at 500. that's the setup
let's get into The Benchmark charts and
then we'll show you the summary chart at
the end just like with the 7800 XT
review we'll start with star field it's
new and it's a very heavy workload at
least now we'll see if that stays the
same and that makes it particularly
relevant to amd's benefit star field is
also currently running better on AMD
cards price to price than on Nvidia
cards at 4K High the 7700 XT ran at 39
FPS average the lows for one percent
with 31 and 24 for 0.1 percent that has
the RX 7800 XT about 24 ahead of the
7700 XT while costing 11 more money
we're wondering if this is a classic
upsell here from AMD because the
performance gap between them is larger
than the price Gap might otherwise
suggest and consider that companies
normally have two options to take in
this position either they can have a
tiny Gap that allows the cheaper card to
be the best value or a larger Gap that
creates an upsell scenario we're not
surprised to see the latter either way
compared to the 6700 XT the 7700 XT
leads by 28 percent it also leads the
RTX 4060 TI which is currently about 380
to 400 and the Gap there is a 29
Advantage for the 7700 XT the 4070 is
about tied including in lows allowing
AMD a value advantage in this current
game version the 7800 XT would be the
most obvious Step Up in terms of value
to price Gap at least near this price
point for the 77. at 1440p high there
rx7700 XT roughly ties the RTX 3080 and
outpaces the 6700 XT by 24 the lead over
the 46 TI is about 28 similar to before
and the 7800 XT is extra 50 boosts it 27
over the 7700 XT that's more of a lead
than at 4K for other options you could
consider a used 6800 XT if you're
willing to put up with secondhand cards
in that case it outperformed the 7700 XT
by about 15 finally at 1080p High we
start seeing a CPU Bond at the top of
the charge where the 700 XT the 40 90
the 4080 to some extent but the Lesser
one and the 7800 XT are all starting to
bounce off of the cpu's capabilities the
7900 XT would be the same hence why it
wasn't included it's pointless here uh
they are all hitting limits so the 7700
XT is still at least far from that
ceiling the 7800 XT leads it by 22
despite occasionally hitting the ceiling
which is contributing to a little bit of
the reduction in that performance
Advantage as compared to 1440 that is
the 6800 XT is about 14 ahead of the
7700x and generationally amd's new card
is about 20 ahead of the 6700 XT Dying
Light 2 is new to our test Suite so the
GPU list is more limited to what we
could do between Star field test passes
in the past two weeks at 4K the RX 7700
XT ran at 38 FPS average or so allowing
the 4070 Elite of 11 the 7800 XT had a
lead of 21 over the 7700 xte and the
7700xc improves by 15 over the 6700 XT
but the 7800 XT still manages to
complicate the choice around the 77
versus the 78 given the disproportionate
Improvement to the 7800 XT as opposed to
its price increase the 4060 TI is far
enough down the stack to not be too much
of a consideration at this price range
unless you were already seriously
considering it at 1440p the 7800 xt's
lead drops to about 17 to 18 down from
21 as we've seen in the past increasing
the resolution can illustrate advantages
of a GPU that emerged from higher CU
counts or rap counts or any other
individual resource within the GPU core
the 4070s lead also climbs this time to
about 13 from 11 and as for cheaper
options the Improvement in the 7700 XT
over the 6700 XD is 14 or about the same
as against the 4060 TI actually Intel's
orac a770 is just below both of these
entries until it doesn't have an arc
competitor in the upper ranks of GPU
competition right now but it does have
overall strengths and the more
affordable Market we're still not bound
by the CPU for the 7700 XT at least at
1080p here the card ran at about 100 FPS
average but in the 40 70 17 ahead the
4070s lead is gaining as resolution
decreases for this game whereas the 7800
XT now at a similar lead of 17 is seen
less significance as opposed to the 4K
result although uh it hasn't dropped too
much up next in Resident Evil 4 at 4K
the RX 7700xc ran about 60 FPS average
now that lands it just under the 4070 at
63 FPS average allowing nvidia's more
expensive 4070 a lead of about 4.7
percent in rasterization here the 6800
XD might be better value than either of
the two new AMD cards depending on if
you can still get it around or under 500
as it manages to outperform the 7800 XT
by six percent and the 7700 XT by 27 as
for the 7800 XT that's ahead of the 7700
XT by a 19.7 percent 1440p has the 7700
XT at 119 FPS the 7800 XT is at 136. the
6800 XT is at 143 and the 4070 TI is at
164. respectively that means that these
gpus lead the 7700 XT by 14 20 and 38
percent compared against the last
generation the 7700 XT is 30 ahead of
the 6700 XT we won't spend much time on
1080p the 7800 XT here led the 77
XT by 15 with the red rest of the GPU is
scaling similarly to before in total
Warhammer at 4K the 7700xc landed
between the 6800 XT and the 4060 TI it's
ahead of the 4060 TI by about 13 here
and it's ahead of the 6700 XT
generationally by about 27 it's also
ahead of the 4060 by 35 although pricing
is obviously a different story in the
opposite direction moving to the 7800 XT
would push performance up by 27 percent
in exchange for the extra fifty dollars
the 4070 would post about the same
performance gain here although for an
extra 100 bucks over the 7800 XT AMD
definitely positioned these two to force
a hard choice between them at 1440p the
RX 7700 XT ran at 96 FPS average
allowing the 7800xc to establish an
advantage of 20 that's not as much as 4K
so for at least this game the 7800 XD
has a disproportional benefit at the
higher resolution will need to pay
attention to see if that continues in
other games compared to other cards the
7700 XT leads the 4060 TI by 20 as well
with the lead over the last gen 6700 XT
at about 27 High run to options could
increase performance by 43 moving to the
4070 TI and 66 percent at the 7900 XT
level at 1080p for this game we're most
interested in the scan against the 7800
XT the higher end option ran at 177 FPS
average leading the 7700 XT by 16 that's
another reduction against what we saw at
4K and 1440p so the lead diminishes and
becomes less significant as resolution
decreases that'll be again important to
keep in mind as we continue forward for
other comparisons the scaling is more
similar the lead over the 6700 XT
remains about 27 with a lead over the
4060 TI at about 18 so not much has
changed here in Tomb Raider at 4K the
rx3700xc is 74 FPS average has the 7800
XT 25 ahead it's pretty consistent with
some of the previous games compared to
the 400 460 TI 8 gigabyte the lead is 12
by the 7700 XT or 37 as compared to the
4060 but for 50 more money at 1440p the
rx7800 XT leads the 7700 XT by 17 that's
not nearly as good as we saw at 4K and
it also matches some of the previous
scaling reduction as resolution Falls
this is one of the more interesting
stories emerging from this particular
review the 7800 XT is often
disproportionately more interesting as
an alternative as your interest in the
higher resolution gaming increases as
for other comparisons the 7200 XT leads
the 4060 TI by just 11 here the lead
over the last gen 6700 XT was 13 at
1080p the 7800 XT only leads the 7700 XD
by 10 making it appear much less worth
the fifty dollars part of that increase
is because we're approaching a CPU bind
around 240 FPS average or so so some
spikes are truncated but part of it is
because of the already shown reduction
at Advantage alongside reduction in
resolution in Horizon zero Dawn the 7800
XT is back to its 26 lead when at 4K at
85 FPS average to 67 FPS average lows
are proportional here as well so nothing
exciting different there the 7700 XT is
capable of 4K gaming in some scenarios
like this one and as for its
generational Improvement we saw a 19
improvement over the 6700 XT the 4060 TI
sticks close to its prior Gap where the
7700xc holds a 14 lead at 1440p the 7700
XT runs at 133 FPS average against the
7800 XT is 162 FPS average establishing
a lead for the 7800 XT at 22 percent
that's a reduction of about four
percentage points compared to the 4K
test so the pattern is emerging here as
well in Final Fantasy at 4K the 7700 XT
runs at 68.9 FPS average putting it
close to the old 1080 TI and about seven
percent ahead of the 6700 XT or similar
ahead of the 4060 TI the 7800 XT leads
the 7700 XT by 23 here similar to many
of the other games now raytrace testing
is up next we're keeping it really brief
this time just because we have so many
other charts in this one and we want to
add some Ray Trace testing for some of
the new games we've added to the suite
but just to do some Basics starting with
f122 with rt on we found the 7700 XT to
run at 29 FPS average without using any
type of upscaling purely in the
comparative that has both the 6800 XT
and the 7800 XT about 11 ahead the 4070
is now a 17 ahead so as usual in the
past we see on video showing some more
relative capability in its RT
performance specifically the same shows
up for the 4060 TI which closes the Gap
to eight percent here let's move to a
more playable resolution at 1440p the
7700 XT runs at 57.6 FPS average it's
still eight percent ahead of the 4060 TI
with a 7800 XT 9 ahead and the 4070
still 17 ahead Tomb Raider at 4K with 3D
tracing is next these results aren't
comparable to the earlier Tomb Raider
results because it has RT now the RX
7700xe ran at 40 FPS average here all we
really care about is the percent scaling
relative to other cards so the 78 XT was
29 ahead here with a 6800 XT about the
same the RTX 4070 expanded its lead to
36 in this title with the 4060 TI not
too distant at 1440p the 7700 XT moves
to 81 FPS average reducing the 7800 xt's
lead to 18 and the 40 70s to 29 power
consumption is up now the rx7700xc that
we have consumes more power than our RX
7800 XT that's a difference of model the
7800 XT we have is a reference model
from AMD whereas our 7700 XT is an XFX
unit with higher clocks and an increased
power Target the 7700 XT from XFX ends
up at 268 Watts or 308 when overclocked
that's considerably less efficient even
at stock than the 7800xc reference model
especially given the lower performance
in exchange for more power this is where
we have the new charts so in the 7800xc
review we showed some simple summary
comparison charts with percent scaling
the goal of those is to look at average
FPS as a simple measure and put all the
bars on the chart for all the different
games we tested and show you what the
sort of snapshot is of the percent
uplift from card a versus card b a
percentage math can be unintentionally
misleading like a lot of Statistics
figures you can use and that's because
if you calculate percentages in two
different directions positive and
negative they can kind of diverge and
one might sound better or worse than it
would have used all One Direction
unfortunately in a head-to-head
comparison with two products are close
to each other you're always going to
have some positive some negative so we
try to represent the cards in a way
where it's generally a positive uplift
percent calculation we're doing and then
where they do mix and match you'll have
some negatives but as you approach zero
for the difference that becomes less
relevant all right so for the 7700 XT we
made a simple chart to show its position
against the 7800 XT generally speaking
moving to the 7800 XT from the 72 700 XT
would boost You by 20 to 30 percent at
4K or 10 to 20 at 1080p plus or minus a
bit Final Fantasy at 1080p here will
show no difference it's not because
there isn't a difference between the
cards but because that scenario is
limited by other components and can't
show the differences between these cards
with the test platform 500 is about 11
more money than 450 so if you want to
look at it that way so gaining in the
20s to 30 more performance seems like in
a vacuum of these two cards only a good
trade if you can afford the extra fifty
dollars we do think it's better value to
step up to the 7800 XT what's even
better value though would be stepping up
to the 6800 XT which is currently about
the same price we'll briefly show you
our 7800 XT to 6800 XT chart summary
from the last review in general the 68xt
is a better card when at the same price
or similar in this case the jump from
the 7700 XT to the 68 would be even
larger you get more cus for it too which
helps some applications and some games
this is where we get into some just AMD
things things where AMD has a history of
launching cards like this that in terms
of spacing versus other immediately
available close by options don't always
make a ton of sense on day one uh and
what we've noticed is that AMD tends to
cut prices pretty hastily for some of
its products look at the 7600 they cut
it literally before it launched and
that's not the only case and he
generally does this last couple years
now for Radon so what we wonder is not
that that predicts future actions from
AMD but it might indicate them what we
wonder is if the 7700xc gets a price cut
or if the board Partners start dropping
the prices relative to the 78 models
then it may be the case where say a
hundred dollar price Gap develops and
that starts to knock them into two more
distinctly
sensible categories where they can kind
of operate in their own orbits because
the 50 bucks out of you know 500 it's
pretty close like it's still a good
amount of money yes but it's not
anything like a hundred dollars four
hundred to Five Hundred so we think that
may develop and if that's the case then
it's possible the 7700 XT kind of like
some of these other cards we reviewed in
the last generation become significantly
more interesting just basically out of
nowhere one day because of a price
change so simply put if you can afford
the 50 and it doesn't put pressure on
you then we do still think it's a great
idea to look at the 7800 XD or ideally
the 6800 XT for today options if you're
okay with used like we said in the last
review we've been looking more at used
cards lately the pricing is pretty
impressive if you are willing to put up
with the chance that you might get
screwed or end up with something that is
showing its age a little more than other
brand new cards would then use could be
a great way to save a lot of money at
this point and get something like a 6800
XT one of our viewers actually in our
7800 XT review commented that they had
purchased a 6800 XT for 400 and it was
used from what I I understand and that
is phenomenal pricing for back and
whenever they bought in May or March so
uh that's a good option to consider if
you're okay with some of the the risks
with a used car what is clear though as
we said in the 7800 XT review is that
the 47 and the 4060 TI especially really
just look like bad value here the 4060
TI in particular is an impressive
abomination of at 16 gigabytes
for 500 and the fact that it's already
been cut in price in some places helps
highlight that the 4070 is more
competitive at least it's more expensive
too but the competitive part largely
comes into play in Ray tracing
rasterization amd's actually pretty
competitive for the price against modern
gpus ignoring every all history in the
past that dictates sort of uh value
expectations so strictly speaking for
the 77 XT it does come across as an
upsell to the 7800 XT or the 6800 XT it
may make more sense as prices diverge
but that's it for this review Thanks for
as always subscribe for more if you want
to support our reviews like this one you
go to patreon.com Gamers Nexus to throw
us a few bucks or you go to
store.camersaccess.net describe our
brand new GN 15 15 year anniversary PC
Building mod mat that's on the store
thanks for watching we'll see you all
next time